streaming services that appeal to a
larger variety of viewers than just
anime fans have begun to add anime to
their rotation acknowledging that the
medium is more than just a niche concern
on Netflix right now there are anime
films that run the gamut from old
classics to modern hits here are some of
the very best before Hayao Miyazaki was
a household name he got his start
co-writing and directing the 1979 film
loop on the 3rd the castle of Cagliostro
for this debut he got to work with the
international thief's character our sane
a loop on intellectual property of
monkey punch Kazuki Cole cuttle who
himself borrowed the idea from French
novelist Maurice LeBlanc Lupin is the
cheeky thief who likes to announce his
heist before enacting them dragging his
loyal co-conspirators like Daisuke Jigen
into the fray and getting sidetracked by
the sexy Fujiko minae those familiar
with the loop on the 3rd franchise will
readily admit that Miyazaki's take on
the character differs hugely from monkey
Punch's original manga as well as from
the countless anime adaptations that
followed it in Cagliostro Lupin
discovers that he recently absconded
with tons of counterfeit cash and
decides to find its source once there he
meets a young lady named Clarice who is
betrothed against her will to count
Cagliostro Lupin strikes a deal with his
longtime nemesis Interpol's inspector
zenigata
to rescue Clarice from this dismal fate
Rubens unselfish actions in this film
aren't in keeping with the gentlemen
thief's usual modus operandi but it is
interesting to see how the film priests
ages many of the themes and techniques
Miyazaki would use in his films for
years to come
[Music]
Miyazaki is not the only director who's
lesser-known works have found in me [ __ ]
Netflix Makoto Shinkai has recently
enjoyed fame with his 2016 hit film your
name he was directing plenty of films
before that however including 2013's the
garden of words at the start of the
short moody film high school students
the cowl a Kazuki chooses to skip school
in favour of sketching shoes in the
garden at Shinjuku Gyoen a large park in
Tokyo while there he runs into Yukari
Yukino a mysterious 27 year old woman
who's skipping work to enjoy beer and
chocolate in the park all through the
rainy season the two meet up and get to
know each other and cacao becomes more
and more invested in becoming a
shoemaker and making a pair of shoes for
Yukari when yukatas job and her reasons
for neglecting it become known the pair
finds themselves being pulled apart by
the pressures of society there's heaps
of drama to be had in only 46 minutes
and if you can get over the questionable
adult teen relationship the film is an
absolute treat for the eyes especially
the garden scenery for those looking for
a real tearjerker Netflix has the
exceptional teenage drama a silent voice
based on the 7 volume manga of the same
name by Yoshi Tokyo EMA the film begins
with protagonist Julia Ishida as an
elementary schooler learning that his
class has a new student show Konishi Mia
he and some other boys in his class
begin to pick on her especially after
they all find out that she is deaf he
knows something we're all sick of human
fast forward to high school and showya
regrets the selfish actions of his early
childhood actions which ultimately led
him to being ostracized in the same way
he was attempting to ostracize chocol he
runs into her by chance and realizes
that he wants to make amends for the way
he treated her and as the two begin to
navigate this rocky friendship
julia is able to learn how to make
friends with others as well this is a
truly beautiful film which tackles big
issues like bullying disability and
regrets with sensitivity and an
excellent sense of narrative drama just
make sure you have a box of tissues
alongside your popcorn
you'll need it for the climax for sure
though high school dramas make up a
great deal of anime offerings there are
a fair number of historical selections
available as well in this corner of the
world gives viewers a glimpse of an
average woman's life in the chaos of
World War two Suzu an innocent young
woman from Eva in Hiroshima gets married
to a man named Shu Saku a Navy civilian
she moves to his family's home in coude
and there must contend with the rapidly
shifting expectations placed upon her as
a housewife and a citizen living during
wartime as well as the return of her
childhood friend Tetsu the film largely
takes place from 1944 through 1945
toward the end of World War two but also
provides glimpses of pre and post atomic
bomb Hiroshima but the early war years
depicted is more carefree and humorous
giving way to a more anxious tone as
time passes the fearsome tools of war
are a grim contrast to the traditional
close to nature culture of Hiroshima
this is another film where a
handkerchief would not go unused another
historical film miss Hokusai is based on
the real-life artist Katsushika AE
daughter of the famous hokusai it takes
place during the Edo period when Hokusai
is already in his 50s and considered a
renowned artist in Japan ie is one of
his four daughters and she lives with
him and must put up with his many flaws
all while completing many of his
Commission's without any recognition the
pair live more like roommates than
father and daughter and the film
explores their turbulent relationship as
well as ole's relationship with their
half-sister the blind and sickly all now
this is one of those movies that is far
more about characters than plot but the
characters are so live in the animation
especially when bringing the artists
paintings to life is absolutely lovely
it also provides some insight into the
life of a beloved painter through his
relationships with others as well as the
all-too-familiar story of a brilliant
woman whose work is overshadowed by the
important men in her life
Netflix may not have any of the Studio
Ghibli films for North American
streaming but aside from Miyazaki's film
debut with Lupin the third they also
have studio ponics Mary and the witch's
flower studio pinoke was founded by
Ghibli alumnus
yaki Nishimura and this initial work
from the studio definitely bears a
resemblance to the works of Ghibli both
visually and in tone and theme the movie
based on Mary Stewart's novel the little
broomstick follows the young Mary Smith
who has just moved into her great aunt
Charlotte's very English estate Mary is
bored while she waits for her parents to
arrive and for school to start and she
unfortunately has no aptitude for
helping out with anything around the
house she chooses to explore the
estate's grounds and finds herself
following a pair of cats into the woods
where she discovers a strange purple
flower this flower grants her the power
to fly a broomstick which whisks her
away to a magical school where she
learns that there are drawbacks to
wielding magic powers this is a very fun
and sweet film appropriate for the very
young but still enjoyable for adult
viewers who retain a sense of whimsy
those who are familiar with video games
might recognize the title ninokuni which
is a series of titles in the fantasy
role-playing game genre the film which
was directed by Studio Ghibli animator
Yoshiyuki mimosa and showcases music
from Hayao Miyazaki's longtime
collaborator Joe Hisaishi she has a
standalone story separate from any of
the game plots in the film you and harue
travel to a fantasy world to save their
dying friend Cortana who has a
counterpart in this world who is
likewise in trouble this alternate
reality is populated by adorable fantasy
creatures grave dangers and plenty of
magic so once again even though Studio
Ghibli films are not available on
Netflix those who love the look and feel
of works like Howl's Moving Castle or
castle in the sky will find ninokuni
provides a similar thrilling magical
adventure it's useful to note that
viewers don't need to have any
familiarity with the game series in
order to enjoy this film relationships
are at the core of the three stories in
the chinese-japanese anthology film
flavors of youth the movie is split into
three parts the rice noodles a little
fashion show and love in Shanghai
all three are set in different areas of
modern China but they take plenty of
time to look into each other's
characters past as well
in the rice noodles Joe Ming monologues
about time spent with his grandmother
while eating sungeun noodles lamenting
his inability to find quite the same
flavor since he has grown up and moved
out of his parents home a little fashion
show explores the relationship between a
successful model Yulin was providing for
her younger sister Lulu student with
dreams of fashion design
Yulin is putting herself under extra
pressure concerned that her aging will
get in the way of her career she starves
herself while Lulu tries to remind her
to take care of herself
the final segments love and Shanghai
chronicles the story of li mo a too
serious architect who discovers a
cassette tape from his childhood friend
Jo you among his belongings after he
moves he had neglected to listen to Jo
use message when they were still kids
and doing so would have changed the
entire course of his life afterward no
matter what I do I can't get you out of
my mind
at about 75 minutes this Netflix
original anime film is beautifully
animated and touching The Melancholy
ending on a positive note
aside from standalone films there are
plenty of movies that tie into beloved
anime series such as Inuyasha
fortunately for fans Netflix actually
has all four of the Inuyasha films
available to stream it's best to start
at the beginning however with the first
of these films affections touching
across time in this film a demon named
menu Maru has been released from his
imprisonment to take vengeance against
Inuyasha whose father defeated men whom
Otto's father two hundred years
previously under the enchantment of men
who modders lackeys Kagome ends up
pinning Inuyasha back to the tree where
she found him at the start of the anime
series her guilt and some prodding from
Inuyasha's former lover kikyo drive
Kagome back to her own era the modern
age where she finds she is still able to
communicate with Inuyasha through time
and she finds the strength to return to
the feudal era and help her friends
defeat the demon who is threatening them
all this is an excellent choice for
anyone who's feeling nostalgic for those
late nights they spent watching Inuyasha
on Adult Swim rooting for Inuyasha and
Kagome to finally come to terms with
their feelings for each other though
like the series itself the film keeps
that slow burn going strong though the
berserk manga has been running in Japan
since the late 80s and has seen various
anime adaptations since the late 90s
there is something about Kentaro Mira's
dark fantasy series that keeps
cultivating new fans those fans can't
possibly miss the three films that adapt
the mangas Golden Age arc all of which
are available on Netflix the first
chapter in this series of films the egg
of the king follows series protagonists
guts who finds himself forced to join
the company of Griffith leader of the
band of the hawk the two men come across
a demon named Nosferatu Zod who warns
guts about Griffith there's plenty of
intrigue and violence as a failed
assassination attempt force's guts to do
something that even though he is a
hardened mercenary fills him with guilt
and regret the egg of the king sets the
stage for the complicated relationship
between guts and Griffith so viewers
will want to follow this installment up
with the battle for dole Dre and the
event thus completing the arc director
masaaki yuasa already an established
director in japan skyrocketed to western
fame at the beginning of 2019 with his
extremely successful adaptation of goal
'no guys devil man in the Netflix
original series devil man crybaby since
then his films the night is short walk
on girl
Lou over the wall and ride your wave
have graced movie screens all over
America who over the wall is now
streaming on Netflix bringing you asses
delightfully strange animation style
into living rooms everywhere the film
centers on moody high school student Kai
lives in a quiet fishing village and
enjoys producing music in a spare time
when he posts a video of his work online
a couple of school mates u-haul and
kunio see it and convinced him to join
their band they practice out on merfolk
Island a place tied to the town's
legends about fearsome mermaids while
playing the music kai here's a mermaid
song and becomes friends with Lou a tiny
mermaid with a penchant for singing of
course he tries to keep Luis secret from
the town until she plays a concert with
their band and accidentally becomes
famous the movie explores the
relationship between Kai and Lu as well
as the harmful prejudices humankind
perpetuates the visuals don't disappoint
with Yuasa signatures stretched out
movement sequences in full force for
jazzed up dance numbers and all kinds of
water acrobatics check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about anime are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you